Trascrizione: Simona Vasile
Revisore: Chiara Vallasciani
Buonasera,
sono Stefano Micelli
questa sera vi parlo di artigiani
Artigiani del Futuro,
magari proverò ad allargare il campo,
parlando
di quella che può essere
la manifattura italiana nel futuro
ma andiamo per passi.
Prima di tutto una nota di spiegazione
di solito quando si parla di artigianato
si parla di passato,
di un passato magari
ricordato in modo malinconico
difficile che un argomento del genere
possa far parte di una conferenza TED
o altri format simili a questo.
Quando noi pensiamo agli artigiani
la figura più ricorrente,
l'idea che ci salta
immediatamente in mente
è quella di Geppetto alle prese
con il suo burattino Pinocchio,
un prodotto tra l'altro
di grandissimo successo.
Ma abbiamo molta difficoltà
a declinare al presente e al futuro
una figura che abbiamo legato
per molti aspetti al passato.
In più, di solito quando parliamo dei mali
che affliggono l'economia italiana,
quando ragioniamo sui media,
discutiamo sui media
di quello che è il peso
della tradizione italiana,
del vincolo
che ci impedisce di guardare in avanti,
spesso parliamo
di quelle piccole imprese
che tanto hanno a che fare
nel nostro immaginario
con quella tradizione artigiana
che per molti è anche il vincolo,
l'ostacolo per guardare
a un futuro più brillante e contemporaneo.
In realtà, lasciatemi dire
il nostro presente
è già un pezzo di artigiano
assolutamente capace
di stare nel presente.
Un primo luogo comune da sfatare
è che spesso i nostri artigiani
lavorano solo nelle piccole imprese,
in realtà, se noi andiamo a vedere
il vantaggio competitivo,
così lo chiamano
gli economisti industriali,
di tante medie e grandi imprese
beh, ritroviamo personaggi
come quelle che vedete alle mie spalle,
trovate persone di grande competenza
che non lavorano in piccole imprese.
Questa è un'immagine che ho tratto
dagli stabilimenti di Firenze di Gucci,
uno dei più importanti
brand italiani nel mondo,
una delle persone che concorre
con il suo lavoro, la sua competenza
a fare quei 3 miliardi di fatturato
che il gruppo Gucci realizza ogni anno.
Immagini molto simili le potremmo trovare
nel mondo dell'arredo casa,
del legno, della produzione di mobili
nel mondo della meccanica,
della meccanica di precisione
laddove si costruiscono
componenti per le automobili
o macchine utensili.
Questo tipo di saperi è oggi
uno dei pezzi interessanti
della nostra manifattura.
Una delle ragioni per cui tante aziende,
come nel caso di Gucci,
straniere
vengono ad investire in Italia.
Non è solo, come si dice oggi "heritage".
Oggi, secondo luogo comune
che voglio sfatare qui con voi,
il lavoro artigiano in Italia
parla anche la lingua dell'innovazione.
Questo che vedete alle mie spalle
è un signore molto famoso all'estero,
che ha inventato una cosa
che si chiama "Scheda Arduino",
un controller, una scheda,
un piccolo computer,
che consente di far parlare Internet,
i nostri computer, con le cose reali.
Ecco, Massimo Banzi
non viene dal mondo della grande impresa,
non è nato,
professionalmente
all'interno di un centro di ricerca
finanziato da una corporation
capace di stabilizzare grandi investimenti
ricerca e sviluppo.
Nasce da una grande passione,
quasi da bricoleur,
come professore a Ivrea,
in un master, inventa una scheda
che trasforma nel primo
prodotto di successo di "open hardware"
e che lo fa diventare un'icona
del nuovo manifatturiero
a livello internazionale.
Così innovano i nostri.
Ho preso Massimo Banzi
perchè oggi è un personaggio globale,
ma ne avremo molti altri
che potremo far vedere.
Perché oggi questi casi interessanti
che vi ho portato all'attenzione,
devono essere in qualche modo
presi molto sul serio?
Perché nel futuro possiamo immaginare
una nuova schiera di artigiani
molto digitali, molto internazionalizzati,
molto contemporanei,
capaci di fare un pezzo importante
dell'economia italiana e tout court?
Perché siamo di fronte
a una grande rivoluzione
che voi vedete ben esemplificata in una
bella copertina dell'Economist di mesi fa
che ha a che fare con la
Terza Rivoluzione Industriale.
La prima quella del vapore
che nasce in Inghilterra alla fine del 700
la seconda è quella più americana
della seconda metà dell'800
la terza è quella che ha a che fare
con una nuova idea di manifattura
che mette insieme il digitale,
il signore al computer, con la produzione.
Vi segnalo un aspetto di questo disegno
che trovo molto azzeccato,
da quel nastro trasportatore
voi vedete uscire pezzi tutti diversi.
La manifattura digitale consente di
aggirare, importante per un economista,
il tema delle economie di scala,
produce varietà senza costi particolari.
Quando parliamo di manifattura digitale,
voglio sgombrare il campo,
non parliamo di cose troppo esoteriche,
soprattutto per noi,
parliamo della manifattura sottrattiva
che conosciamo molto bene,
le frese, il controllo numerico
e il laser cutter,
parliamo, questo si,
in campo più innovativo
di quella che oggi gli economisti
chiamano la manifattura additiva,
in particolare le stampanti 3D
che oggi rappresentano davvero
la frontiera della tecnologia,
una frontiera straordinaria,
che promette in tempi molto brevi
di realizzare, con materiali
e strumenti sempre più sofisticati,
cose che fino a poco tempo fa
non immaginavamo assolutamente
di poter produrre
in connessione con un computer.
Cosa possiamo fare con questi strumenti?
Molte cose.
Ma una vera rivoluzione
si ha se l'offerta cambia
a fronte di un cambiamento della domanda.
E la domanda sta cambiando.
Dopo anni di globalizzazione
che ha privilegiato oggetti
più o meno standardizzati,
più o meno di marca,
quello che stiamo registrando,
in particolare nei mercati emergenti,
in particolare in Cina.
Proprio su questo argomento
varrebbe la pena riflettere
soprattutto per noi italiani
che vendiamo prodotti sofisticati.
La domanda oggi chiede più varietà.
E in alcuni casi la chiede
soprattutto attraverso la rete.
Questo è un portale emblematico,
da questo punto di vista,
è il portale "Ez.com" che davvero
rappresenta la bandiera
di coloro che pensano a un capitalismo
in cui la domanda chiede oggetti specifici
chiede cose molto particolari
e le chiede reclamando l'identità
di chi le ha prodotte.
Un incontro "person-to-person"
dicono gli americani.
Per noi tutto questo è un business?
Per noi tutto questo è una frontiera?
E' una delle frontiere tecnologiche
su cui investire?
Si. E voglio rassicurare tutti i presenti
che ci stiamo già scommettendo.
Non abbiamo, in questo senso,
bisogno di troppi editti, proclami,
oggi se andiamo a vedere
cosa sta succedendo nel nostro paese,
qua vicino, a Vicenza,
saremo probabilmente
sorpresi di vedere
che un pezzo importante
di questa innovazione
è già a casa nostra.
Questo è un bellissimo esempio
di un anello, che è stato progettato
in digitale da delle studentesse
del Politecnico di Torino.
Lo hanno prodotto sotto i miei occhi,
io l'ho chiesto.
Lo hanno prodotto
da un punto di vista digitale,
lo hanno passato
attraverso questa stampante,
lo hanno stampato, potremo dire così.
Questo è il risultato,
è stato portato diligentemente a Vicenza
dove è stato fuso, come si dice,
in cera persa da un artigiano italiano
che mi ha consegnato il giorno dopo
un anello per mia moglie.
Un figurone!
Perché la storia è interessate
e edificante?
Non solo perché qui c'è una storia
interessante di nuove tecnologie,
di giovani a lavoro che sono in grado
di progettare quegli oggetti,
ma anche perché questo è il modo
in cui noi mettiamo insieme
queste nuove tecnologie con
un grande patrimonio storico-culturale
che è quello del nostro
artigianato tradizionale.
E' questa fusione che ci rende unici
una delle parti più interessanti
della nostra economia.
E' su questa frontiera
che possiamo dire molto al mondo.
Grazie.